and audiences are filling the seats of a
little-known theater in the arts
district that's making a big name for
itself their current production is
called the sandman and it's getting rave
reviews for being scary good
i'd like to tell a little
right now we're doing the american
premiere of a show called the sand man a
little nightmare musical this nightmare
musical could become a dream come true
for a little neighborhood theater that's
making big headlines with a possible
broadway hit
[Music]
it's edgy it's dark it's funny it's
filled with heart owner and artistic
director troy hurd has poured his heart
soul and savings into the majestic
repertory theater that looks like most
any other storefront in reinvented
downtown las vegas it spent its five
years upstaged by vintage vibe shops and
distinctive new eateries but the
spotlight is finally shining on this
funky 70-seat theater that puts the
audience in the middle of the action we
just do really cool stuff a lot of folks
call us a gateway to theater because we
do theater that's not
stuffy not pretentious it's very
accessible and a heck of a lot of fun
and that's just what a broadway riding
team was looking for when they called
troy to stage their tim burton-like
musical i said well you found the right
place i have traveled far
mostly in the east
studying with the yogis my knowledge
increased
meditative tools the attraction to the
sandman is is a chance to create a
fantasy world on stage the talent is all
local from the actors to stage designers
even wardrobe hair and makeup are the
works of las vegas cirque du soleil
professionals people are loving it and
producers are flying in to see it we
built an audience like we've had sell
out shows pretty much from our
beginnings you know people just want to
come down here and they know when they
come to majestic you're going to be
right in the middle of the action you're
going to see something different and
you're going to see something that
you're going to remember forever
well the show has been so popular now
that the performances have been extended
thursday through sunday performances of
the sandman are now extended through
december 12th tickets are 35 for adults
25 for 18 and under you can find the
link to buy tickets on our website troy
doesn't recommend the show for kids
under 10 or anyone who still hides under
their covers at night in the dark uh-oh
because as you could see there some of
the lighting was dim and dark and
there's some fog yeah there's sounds and
this is an immersive theater all right
so you're literally sitting right by the
stage and there are sounds all around
you
underneath you
everywhere okay and secret passageways
and all kinds of stuff so it includes
the audience the audience leans in
and as troy said you can't get this
sitting on your couch at home watching
netflix
well there's something to be said you
know we talk about the big shows and
adele and keith urban and all the big
shows on the street which are all
fantastic but there's something to be
said for a small little theater where
you're right in the action you're right
with the actors and the actresses
they're doing it's so cool to be that
intimate with the performance and local
talent local like you said people doing
the costuming and the makeup that we
have an incredible talented group of
people here we sure do and you know and
as he said there's a place for
everything here in las vegas you've got
the strip the big lights the glitch the
glamour this is the very local
experience downtown in the arts district
and he said people coming in from out of
town are looking for that they want to
know how the locals live well there you
go and you were saying that it's a small
uh seating
76. 70 seats so you're right there
you're elbowed elbow with your neighbor
part of it i love it terry just got a
good story